The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Let's get started.
Why doesn't everyone go ahead
and take ten more seconds on
the clicker question.
All right, and let's
see how we did.
Alright, excellent job, 86%
of you, that's right.
What we had just done a
clicker question on is
discussing light as a particle
and the photoelectric effect,
so we're going to finish up with
a few points about the
photoelectric effect today.
And then we're going to try a
demo to see if we can convince
ourselves that the kind of
calculations we make work out
perfectly, and we'll do
a test up here about
half way through class.
And we'll also talk about photon
momentum as another
example of light behaving
up as a particle.
After that, we'll move on to
matter as a wave, and then the
Schrodinger equation, which is
actually a wave equation that
describes the behavior of
particles by taking into
account the fact that matter
also has these wave-like
properties.
So, starting back with the
photoelectric effect -- yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] class last
time [INAUDIBLE] notes.
PROFESSOR: Oh, sure.
Can one of the TAs maybe come up
and hand around anyone that
didn't get notes?
We have not yet perfected the
art of entering and exiting
this classroom yet, we're
still working on that.
Raise your hand if you need
notes and we'll make sure we
get those to you.
All right, so where we left
off with the photoelectric
effect was when we first
introduced the effect, we were
talking about it in terms
of frequencies.
So, for example, we were talking
about a threshold
frequency as in a minimum
frequency of light that you
need in order to eject an
electron from a metal surface.
What Einstein then clarified for
us was that we could also
be talking about energies, and
he described the relationship
between frequency and energy
that they're proportional, if
you want to know the energy,
you just multiply the
frequency by Planck's
constant.
So, now we can talk about it
in different terms, for
example, talking about e sub
i, which is the incident
energy or the energy of the
light that comes in, or
talking about work function
here, and that's just another
way to say threshold energy.
So, the work function's the
minimum amount of energy
that's required in order to
eject an electron, and most of
you understand this relationship
here, which is a
little bit cut off, but it is
all the way on in your notes,
and that is what you saw the
clicker question on -- how you
can figure out, for example,
the kinetic energy of the
ejected electron by looking at
the difference between how
much energy you put in and how
much energy is required to
eject that electron in
the first place.
So, in this class we'll be
talking about energy a lot,
and it's often useful to draw
some sort of energy diagram to
visualize the differences in
energy that we're discussing.
So, we do this here for the
photoelectric effect, and in
terms of the photoelectric
effect, what we know the
important point is that the
incoming photon has to be
equal or greater in energy
then the work
function of the metal.
So here we have energy
increasing on the y-axis, and
you see this straight line at
the bottom here is lower down
on the graph, and that's the
energy of a bound electron, so
that's going to be a
low stable energy.
But we see if we have a free
electron, as we do in this
dotted line here, that's going
to be a higher energy that's
less stable.
So, if we want to go from that
stable state to that less
stable state, we need to put in
a certain amount of energy
to our system, and that's what
we define as the work function
here -- that difference between
the free electron and
the electron bound
to the metal.
So, the most basic case to
understand, which is what we
just saw is a case where we
have the incident energy
coming in, and that incident
energy is greater than the
work function, and in that case
what we see is that we
have an electron that
is ejected.
That makes sense and it also
makes sense that this little
extra bit here, that's the
amount of energy that we have
that goes into the kinetic
energy of the electrons.
So, that's how we could
also graph figuring
out the kinetic energy.
So, in the second case what we
have is what happens if we
have the incident energy at some
amount that's less than
the work function, and in this
case we're showing 1/2 of the
work function.
So in this case, we don't have
enough energy to eject an
electron, so, an electron
is not ejected.
And that's pretty clear, too,
and the question I want to
pose to you is instead
the third case here.
So in the third case what I'm
showing is that we have -- now
we're not just talking about 1
photon, we're talking about 3
photons -- let's say we shoot
them all at the same time at
our metal, each of them having
some energy that's let's say
1/2 the work function.
So, just to take a little bit
of an informal survey, who
thinks here that we will have
an electron that is
ejected in this case?
So a couple hands, all right.
And what about who thinks
that we will not have
enough energy here?
All right.
We've got a big majority, and
both are logical ways of
thinking, but it turns out that
the majority is correct,
which is not always the case,
but the electron is not
ejected in this case.
And the reason for this, and
this is a very important point
about the photoelectric effect,
and the point here is
that the electrons here are
acting as particles, you can't
just add those energies
together.
One individual particle is being
absorbed by the metal
and exciting an electron.
So, having other particles
around that have the same
energy that you could
technically add up if you were
adding them up like a wave, you
can't do the same thing
with particles, they're
all separate.
So, the take-home message is
whether you have three photons
or 3,000,000 photons that you're
shooting at your metal,
if you're not at that minimum
frequency or that minimum
energy that you need, nothing
is going to happen.
So, you might ask then well what
is the significance of
shooting different amounts
of photons at a metal?
Is there any significance at
all, for example, in the
number of photons that are
hitting the metal or being
absorbed by the metal.
And there is a relationship
here, and that is that the
number of photons absorbed by
the metal are related to the
number of electrons ejected
from the metal.
So, in this figure here what I'm
actually showing is these
little sunshines, which
let's say are each
one individual photon.
So we had six photons going in,
so the maximum number of
electrons that we're going to
have coming out is also six
because the maximum scenario
that we could have that would
maximize the number of electrons
is that each one of
those photons comes in, excites
an electron, ejects it
from the surface of the metal.
It's important to note, of
course though, it's not just
the number, it's really
important that the energy of
each one of these individual
photons is, of course, greater
than the work function
of the metal.
So, that's, in fact, it's that
number of photons that we're
talking about when we refer to
the intensity of light, and
the intensity of light is
proportional to that number,
because when we talk about
intensity, really we're
talking about the amount of
energy that a stream of
particles, a stream of photons,
has per second.
So, if we have a high intensity,
we're talking about
having more photons per second,
and it's important to
know also what that
does not mean.
So it does not mean that we have
more energy per photon.
This is a really important
difference.
Intensity, if we increase
the intensity, we're not
increasing the energy in each
photon, we're just increasing
the number of photons that
we're shooting out of our
laser, whatever our
light source is.
And when we talk about intensity
in terms of units,
we usually talk about watts,
so if you change your
lightbulb, usually you see the
intensity in terms of watts.
But in terms of SI units, which
become much more useful
if you're actually trying to use
intensity in a problem and
cancel out your units, we're
just talking about joules per
second is what intensity is.
So at this point, you should
be able to have all the
background you need on the
photoelectric effect to solve
any type of problem that we
throw at you, and you see
three on this problem set, and
we'll probably give you one
more on your next problem set,
and the reason we ask you so
many questions about the
photoelectric effect is
because it actually is very
similar to ionization energy
that we'll talk about later,
also problems dealing with
photoelectron spectroscopy.
So, we want to make sure that
this is something the entire
class is 100% solid on.
Sometimes the questions are
worded quite differently, so I
just want to sum up here
the different ways
they could be worded.
For example, if we talk about
photons, of course, we also
just mean light, sometimes
we refer to this as
electromagnetic radiation, and
there's several ways that you
might be asked this in a problem
or that you might be
asked to answer.
Sometimes we might just directly
tell you the energy
of the photon -- that's probably
the easiest scenario,
because when we think about
work functions those are
usually reported in energy.
So since that's the easiest
scenario, you can probably be
sure it's not going to be too
frequently that you're just
given the energy, right,
that might be too easy.
So really what we'll probably do
is instead either give you
the wavelength or the frequency
and you'll go ahead
and calculate the energy
from there.
In terms of talking about the
electrons, I wanted to point
out that in the book and other
places you might see electrons
referred to as photoelectrons.
That's sometimes confusing for
people, because it seems like
okay, is it a photon or
is it an electron.
I just want to clarify that
it is an electron.
It's called this just because
it's an electron that results
when an electron absorbs a
photon's worth of energy, so
thus it's a photoelectron.
And if we talk about electrons
or photoelectrons, again we
can describe it in terms of
energy, we can talk about
velocity, and from there, of
course, you can figure out the
energy from 1/2 m v squared,
and actually we can also
describe the electron in
terms of wavelength.
So you don't actually know
this yet from this class,
you'll know it by the end of the
class that electrons can,
in fact, have a wavelength.
So once we cover it, it will
then be fair game to ask these
photoelectron spectroscopy or
these photoelectric effect
questions using the wavelength
of the electron.
Also to point out, a lot of
times you'll see electron
volts instead of joules, this is
the conversion factor here
just so you all have
it in your notes.
All right.
So let's test what we, in
fact, know about the
photoelectric effect, and before
we do that actually,
we're going to calculate what
we would predict, so when we
do the demo it will be
meaningful and we can tell
whether we're successful
or not.
So hopefully we will
be successful.
And as I point this out, we now
know how to do any kind of
photoelectric effect problem,
also this means you should be
able to go back to Monday's
notes where we filled in all
those graphs, which were what
different scientists were
observing when they were
measuring either the frequency
or the intensity of light that
was irradiating different
types of metals, and also the
number of electrons ejected,
and the kinetic energy of
those electrons ejected.
You should be able to maybe
print out a blank copy of
those notes from the website and
fill in all those graphs
-- not for memorizing them, but
now just understanding how
the photoelectric effect works.
All right.
So let's do an in-class problem,
and this will be done
with zinc. We have a zinc plate
up here, and we're going
to -- in a minute I'll describe
how we can probe if
electrons are coming
off of it.
But we're going to irradiate
it with two
different light sources.
We have a UV lamp right here,
which is centered at a
wavelength of 254 nanometers.
And then since we have my red
laser pointer, we will also
try with the red laser pointer,
which is centered at
wavelength of 700 nanometers.
So, there are a few questions
that we need to answer first.
So we want to see, do we expect
to eject electrons off
of this metal surface, or do we
expect that we don't have
enough energy?
So that means we're going to
need to figure out what is the
energy per photon that's emitted
by that UV light.
Also, what's the energy per
photon of this red laser
pointer, and then it's also
worth trying a calculation
dealing with intensity.
So let's also try calculating
the numbers of photons that
would be emitted by this laser
pointer, if, for example, we
were to use it for 60 seconds
and this were a
one milliwatt laser.
So, let's do some of these
calculations starting first
with what is the energy per
photon, and let's start with
the UV lamp.
So we know that energy is equal
to Planck's constant
times nu, but what we know
about the lamp is its
wavelength, or the light
that's emitted.
We know that nu is equal
to c over wavelength.
So we can figure out the energy
of each photon emitted
by our UV lamp by saying e is
equal to h c over wavelength.
So let's just plug in
these numbers here.
That means our energy is equal
to 6.626 times 10 to the -34
joules times seconds.
And then we have c, the speed
of light, 2.998 times 10 to
the 8 meters per second.
And we want to divide all of
that by our wavelength, and to
keep our units the same
we'll do meters.
So that's 254 times 10
to the -9 meters.
So hopefully if some of you
have your calculators with
you, you can confirm the answer
that I got, which is
that the energy is 7.82 times
10 to the -19 joules.
So, remember what we're talking
about here is the
amount of energy that's
in each photon.
So if we think about the work
function for zinc, and the
work function for zinc is 6.9
times 10 to the -19 joules, do
we expect that when we shine
our UV light on the zinc,
we'll be able to eject
electrons?
What do you think?
Yes.
Good.
OK, anyone disagree?
No, OK and that's correct,
because each photon of light
actually has more
energy than is
needed to eject an electron.
So, we would expect to see
electrons ejected with the UV
light source.
So let's now think about using
instead the amount of energy
per photon in that red
laser pointer.
So again, we know that energy
is equal to h c divided by
wavelength, and energy is equal
to -- you have written
out in your notes what the
actual value for h c is, but
now our wavelength is 700 times
10 to the -9 meters.
And what we end up with for the
energy then is 2.84 times
10 to the -19 joules.
All right.
So please raise your hand now
if you think there'll be
sufficient energy to
eject electrons
from the metal surface?
And raise your hands if you
think there won't be.
OK.
Good hand raising technique.
Yes.
In fact, there is not enough
energy in a single photon to
go ahead and eject an electron
from this zinc surface.
So our last question we ask is
what's the total number of
photons emitted if we
give this given
intensity for 60 seconds?
So, keep in mind that one
milliwatt is just the same as
saying 1 times 10 to the
-3 joules per second.
So we have 1 times 10 to the -3
joules per second, and we
want to multiply that by -- or
cancel out how much energy we
have per photon, first of all,
so how much energy do we have
per photon if we're talking
about the red laser pointer?
Right.
So this value right here.
So for every photon
we have 2.84 times
10 to the -19 joules.
We're saying let's do
this for 60 seconds.
So what we end up with for the
number of photons in this
laser beam of light is 2.1 times
10 to the 17 photons.
So this gives you a little bit
of an idea of just how many
individual photons there are
in a laser beam of light.
This is a huge number
of photons.
So the question is
does this matter?
How about if we shoot
this many photons?
Does it make any difference at
all in terms of whether we can
eject an electron?
No, it actually doesn't.
It is an impressive number, it
is very, very large, but it
doesn't make a difference.
So we see that we do not eject
electrons in the case of the
laser pointer, even if we have
this intensity, even for 60
seconds -- it is still not
related to the energy of an
individual photon, so we
won't see an effect.
All right.
So let's hope that we can
confirm our predictions here
by actually doing it, and
Professor Drennen well help me
out by loading up our device
with electrons, and I'll
explain exactly what our set up
here is as she does that.
So basically what we have
is this zinc plate here.
So that's what we want to load
up with electrons, and then
see if we can remove some.
But that's a little bit hard,
we aren't all that good at
seeing electrons with our eyes,
so we need to think of a
way to do this.
So what she's going to do
is start loading up the
electrons, and you see this wand
here move slowly, and it
takes a while to do it, start
become perpendicular.
The reason for that is because
all of this is connected, so
we're moving electrons
everywhere in the system.
And since we have two bars that
are together like this,
once they're both loaded up with
electrons there's going
to be negative charges that
repel, so the electrons will
want to get as far away as
possible, and they're on their
slow way to doing that, to
getting as far away from each
other as possible.
And if we do, in fact, hit
it with light to get the
electrons off, it will go back
to the straight up in
position, or if it gets
knocked hard enough
it does that, too.
Sometimes it's easier actually
not touch it to the metal, I
should have--
TA: It's hard to see if
it's moving or not.
PROFESSOR: So, our technology
TA is also our paper TA.
Darcy will hold up
the yellow paper.
Right, there we go, now we're
making a little progress.
TA: It was moving before, you
just couldn't see it.
PROFESSOR: So, does anyone have
any questions about the
set up here, does it make sense
what we're looking for
the bar to go back once
we make some progress.
This demo works wonderfully in
the winter months in Boston
when we will all be full
of static at all times.
We're still close enough to the
summer that the air is not
just filling us up with extra
static electricity, so it's a
little more challenging here.
We'll try to make this
happen only once.
I think that's probably,
if we can get one more.
So, it works, I think it's
just getting too much
[INAUDIBLE].
Sometimes it helps to not
actually hit the metal, just
put it next to the
-- there we go.
I wonder if there's some UV
light out of this new lighting
set up in our classroom here.
That would be a little tricky.
All right.
I think this -- if
this sticks.
Yeah, it's the pressure
of the paper.
I think that's good enough,
we'll be able to see.
If you can keep showing that,
though, Darcy, we'll try
different scenarios and
I'll try not to put
laser in your eye.
Actually you can look down as
well as an added precaution.
OK, let's try it with that.
That's enough then.
So, the first thing we're going
to try is with the red
laser pointer, because that we
are expecting not to have an
effect, and that will prevent
Professor Drennen from having
to charge up our apparatus
again.
So, Darcy will look down at this
moment and we will hit
this with the laser pointer, and
what we see is nothing is
happening at all.
OK, good.
Control one working.
So now very carefully take
our UV light source --
Darcy again will divert
her eyes and her skin.
Let me make sure this
is actually on.
OK, so we've got UV light here,
and let's see what we
can see, and we lose
electrons, if
that's what's happening.
And it often doesn't go all the
way, because actually this
device gets stuck right there.
So let's charge it up again and
see if we can check again.
But did you see movement?
Are you buying our story here?
This is actually very
representative of when you do
research in the laboratory, you
will find often things do
not work quite exactly as they
worked 20 minutes ago when you
just checked it in your
office, for example.
And sometimes it's a matter of
factors that you need to
figure out what it is, and maybe
it's that there's extra
light in the room we
don't know about.
It might just be -- so,
we did get it back to
the starting position.
Next time maybe we'll charge
it up before class.
All right.
So we kind of saw what was
happening here, you saw it
move a little bit.
They'll keep trying to get it
going, but maybe we should
move on with our lives here
while this is happening, and
we'll click it back at the end,
and if we have a nice set
up at any point, I'll just stop
and we'll go back and
we'll look at it again.
Since, I think that's just not
going to happen right now.
So let's switch, actually,
back to our notes.
So, ideally what we did see
was, in fact, it does have
enough energy with the UV lamp,
it wasn't a dramatic
shift you saw because we didn't
start very high and
then it went to that
stuck point.
But luckily we had the control
of the red laser pointer where
nothing moved at all.
So hopefully you're convinced
that your predictions worked
well and you are able to predict
what's going on when
you're looking at the
photoelectric effect.
So, it turns out that the
photoelectric effect is not
the only evidence for the fact
that light has these
particle-like characteristics.
And one thing that Einstein
put forth is he figured if
well, what we're saying is
that light is, in fact, a
stream of particles, each one of
those particles or photons
must, therefore, have
a momentum.
And that's really neat to think
about, because photons,
of course, are massless
particles, they have no mass,
so it's neat to think about
something that has no mass,
but that actually does
have a momentum.
And the relationship that he put
forth is that the momentum
is equal to Planck's constant
times nu divided by the speed
of light, or it's often more
useful for us to think about
it in terms of wavelength.
So, since the speed of light
equals lambda nu, we can say
that momentum is equal to
h divided by lambda.
And there was experimental
evidence that came along that
supported this, and this is
called the Compton scattering
experiment, and this was done
by Arthur Compton, and
basically what he did was he
took x-ray light, which had
some frequency, which was a very
high frequency because it
was x-rays, and he shot it
at a stationary electron.
And what he was able to observe
was that the electrons
scattered and now had some
momentum, and that both the
frequency, and therefore, the
momentum of the light that he
shot in, went down once
it was scattered.
So what he's showing here is,
first of all, that the light
has some momentum and when it
hits an electron it can
actually transfer some of that
momentum to the electron.
So the transfer of momentum from
a photon to an electron
is what was being observed, and
it was seen as completely
separate evidence to the
photoelectric effect that,
yes, in fact, light is
behaving in these
particle-like ways.
So up to this point, before it
was really established that
yes, light is like a particle
sometimes, there was this very
strong distinction
between what is
light and what is matter.
And the distinction was when
we're talking about light,
light is a wave, and when we're
talking about matter,
well, matter is a particle.
And these behave completely
separate, they don't overlap
at all in terms of behavior, but
then, of course, with the
photoelectric effect with
Compton's scattering, what we
see is that, oh actually,
sometimes photons behave as if
they're particles.
So now this relationship's
beginning to get a little bit
fuzzy in terms of what is the
difference between how we
treat light and matter.
And actually, this was taken
a step further by Louis de
Broglie who in his PhD thesis,
as part of his work as a
graduate student, put forth the
idea that, OK, Einstein
says, and everyone agrees
that, in fact, light is
particle-like at times, and
light, in fact, of course has
a wavelength, and if it has a
wavelength we're saying that
it can have momentum.
And what de Broglie said is
well, if it's true that light,
which has a wavelength can have
momentum, then it must
also be true that matter, which
has momentum, also has a
wavelength.
And you can look at this
in two different ways.
One is that he's just
re-arranged an equation here
and gotten both his PhD thesis
and a Nobel Prize, but I think
the more representative way to
think about this is the real
revolutionary idea that he put
forth, which is that matter
can actually behave as a wave.
And in terms of equations that
we use, it's sometimes easier
to plug in the fact, since
momentum is equal to mass
times velocity.
We can know the wavelength of
any matter -- and he's not
limiting this, for example,
to electrons.
What de Broglie is saying we can
know the wavelength of any
matter at all, as long
as we know its
mass and it's velocity.
And Einstein credited de
Broglie, which is a fair
statement of lifting a corner
of the great veil, because
really there was this
fundamental misunderstanding
about what the difference was
between matter and light, and
the reality is that they can
both be like-particles and
they can both show
characteristics of waves.
So I mentioned, however, that in
terms of de Broglie's work.
This was Nobel Prize worthy,
absolutely, but it was also
his PhD thesis.
So, we can think about what
would happen if we're on his
thesis defense, we're on his
thesis committee, we would
need to think of some pretty
mean, hard, nasty questions to
be asking de Broglie about this
theory -- that's what
happens when you defend
your thesis.
This is necessary, it's hard to
find holes in a Nobel Prize
worthy idea.
But let's just try maybe one
of the basic questions they
could ask, and they can say, all
right, de Broglie, so you
say that all matter, absolutely
all matter has
wave-like behavior.
Why is it that we're never
observing this, for example,
why is it the table doesn't
defract as we bring
it through the door?
Why don't we see the influence
of the wave-like behavior on
every day matter?
So it turns out that he could
have picked anything to
explain this, and hopefully done
out the calculation, and
we'll do this ourselves.
And the example we'll pick is
considering, for example, a
Matsuzaka fastball.
So, many of you are new to the
Boston area, now I still
realize, and I want to let you
know it's not required that
you be a Red Sox fan
to be at MIT.
We do encourage it, however,
and in general, I find you
don't have to give up that old
team, you can keep your old
team, even if it's teams
I won't name, just
keep them to the side.
And you can join on to the Red
Sox nation on top of that, and
part of being a good Red Sox fan
is knowing the statistics
of your team.
For example, if we're talking
about a pitcher, like
Matsuzaka, we might want
to know the speed
of his average fastball.
We might want to know his ERA.
If you're really into it and
you're at MIT, maybe you want
to know the wavelength of
these average fastballs.
So, let's go ahead
and look at that.
So, if we're trying to figure
out the wavelength of a
Matsuzaka fastball, we need to
consider the velocity first,
which is 42 miles per hour.
We don't usually do our
chemistry calculations in
miles per hour, so let's switch
that to 42 meters per
second, so it's -- sorry,
it's 94 miles per hour.
And we can use the de Broglie
relationship that wavelength
should be equal to h over
mass times volume.
And we can put up here Planck's
constant -- and I
want to make note that instead
of writing joules per second,
I actually wrote out
with a joule is.
A joule is a kilogram meter
squared per second squared.
Occasionally, you'll find you
need to cancel out units,
because, of course, you're
always doing unit analysis as
you solve your problems, and
sometimes you'll need to
convert joules to
kilogram meters
square per second squared.
We divide that by the mass, so
0.12 kilograms, that's the
mass of a regulation baseball
for the major leagues, and the
velocity of the baseball is
42 meters per second.
So, we can cross out our units
doing our unit analysis.
The seconds cross out, the
kilograms cross out, one of
the meters crosses out from the
top, so we're left with an
answer in meters.
It's always good when we're
looking for a wavelength that
our answer is in a
unit of length,
that's a good sign already.
And what we find out is the
wavelength of a Matsuzaka
fastball is 1.1 times 10
to the -31 meters.
So, this is really small, this
is undetectably small.
And especially when we consider
it, what tends to be
important is the size of
wavelength in relationship to
its environment.
So 1.1 times 10 to the -31
meters is not, in fact, a
significant number when we're
comparing it, for example, to
the length of a ball, or the
size of the baseball field.
So that would probably be de
Broglie's answer for why, in
fact, we're not observing the
wavelength behavior of
material on a day-to-day life.
So, that's for Matsuzaka, and
even if you don't memorize all
the wavelengths for
all the pitchers.
I would expect, whether you're
a Red Sox fan or not, you to
be able to look at a list of
different pitchers and their
average velocity for their
fastball, and tell me who has
the longest or the shortest
wavelength.
You should all be able to
know that relationship.
So why don't we go to a clicker
question here, and see
if you can tell us this.
So we have 4 different pitchers
we're showing here --
they all have different
strengths.
It's not always how fast you
throw the fastball, sometimes
it's your different styles or
the different ways that you
decide when to throw what.
So, first we have Matsuzaka
at 94 miles per hour.
So, click one if you think that
he's going to have the
longest wavelength.
Tim Wakefield on the DL right
now throws a lot slower,
because he has that tricky
knuckle ball, he doesn't need
to throw as fast. Then we have
Beckett who can get up 96 just
on a regular old day.
And Timlin who is about
91 miles per
hour, one of our relievers.
So, why don't you take ten
seconds to do that.
If you can't decide, Timlin is
my favorite ever, so that
would be a good back up choice
if you forgot the relationship
between wavelength and the
relationship between speed.
It looks like, in fact, people
did not forget that
relationship, and only
1% of you humored me.
So, let's see what the correct
answer is, and it is, in fact,
Wakefield, right, because
there's an inverse
relationship between how fast
a particle is going and what
its wavelength is.
So, in terms of wavelength,
Wakefield has the largest
wavelength, but in terms of
being significant, we're still
not even close.
It's still undetectably small.
Yes.
STUDENT: Why doesn't wavelength
go to infinity as
it stops, like a standing
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: As it stops.
So, let's think.
I would think that it would
approach inifinity, and I
would need to think about it and
get back to you in terms
of why we don't actually hit it
and see something with an
infinite wavelength.
I'm sure there's some upper
limit as there are to most
things, like if we think of
wavelengths and different
types of light, there is so
large that you can get, but
you would be approaching
that level.
All right.
So we can switch back actually
to our notes here --
oh, do we have--?
OK.
We're going to just try this
one more time just
so you can see it.
It'll still likely get stuck in
that spot, but we'll just
show you one more time the
effects of the UV light, and
actually we'll throw in an
extra trick here, too.
We know that UV light gets
absorbed by glass, so it
shouldn't be able to go
through the glass.
So first if Professor Drennen
can try it through the glass,
and we see nothing's
happening.
Let's move the glass away.
All right.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: All right.
Good.
So we can fully believe what
our calculations were now,
which is a nice thing to do.
Let's go back to considering
the wavelengths
of different objects.
We considered a baseball,
but let's also think
about now an electron.
And an electron is something
where, in fact, we might be
able to, if we calculate it and
see how that works out,
actually observe some of its
wave-like properties.
So, if we do this calculation
for an electron, saying it
moves at 10 to the 5 meters per
second, then what we end
up with for a wavelength is 7
times 10 to the -9 meters.
A lot of times we talk about
these kind of distances either
in nanometers or in angstroms
so we can say this is 70
angstroms. So this is, first
of all, even just on an
absolute scale, this is way,
way larger than the
wavelengths we're talking
about for baseball.
In addition, if we compare this
to the diameter of an
atom, which is on the order of
somewhere between one and ten
angstroms, now we're seeing
that, in fact, this wavelength
is significantly larger
than its environment.
So certainly we would expect to
see that it has an effect
in terms of seeing its
wave-like properties.
And this was experimentally
validated, hopefully, even
more clearly than our
experiment here.
And at first this was done by
Davidson and Germer, and they
were American scientists who
tried defracting electrons
from a nickel crystal.
They did this in Bell
Laboratories, and they found
that, in fact, the electronis
did defract.
And G.P. Thompson showed
a similar thing.
What he did was he defracted
electrons through a very thin
gold foil, and this is a picture
-- oops, that is not.
OK.
It is a picture from your book
here showing the defraction
pattern of an electron going
through that gold foil.
So, you can see that, in fact,
it's confirmed that an
electron can have both
wavelength and
particle-like behavior.
And it turns out that Davidson
and Thompson shared a Nobel
Prize for this discovery of
seeing the wave-like behavior
of electrons.
So, this is actually kind of
neat to point out, because we
all remember J.J. Thomson from
our second lecture, and J.J.
Thomson got a Nobel Prize
in 1906 for showing that
electrons exist in that
they are particles.
And it turns out that G.P.
Thompson, well, that's his
son, so we can actually think
of this -- and I'm sure this
wasn't the case, but I like to
think of it as a little bit of
child rebelling against
the father.
So, the father gets a Nobel
Prize for showing that an
electron is a particle, and the
son says, well, what can I
do to top that?
I'm going to show the
exact opposite.
I'm going to say that an
electron's a wave no matter
how much my father says
differently, and I'm going to
get a Nobel Prize for
that, and he does.
But the nice part of the
story is, it turns out
they're both right.
An electron is a particle, but
an electron's also a wave. So,
father and son, happy
ending, they both
have their Noble prizes.
So, what happens now that
we, in fact, know
that matter is a wave?
Well, this allows us to try to
go back and explain some
phenomena that over the years,
mounting evidence was building
that couldn't be explained.
So, for example, when people,
and we'll talk about this next
class, were looking at different
characteristics
spectra of different atoms, what
they were seeing is that
it appeared to be these very
discreet lines that were
allowed or not allowed for the
different atoms to emit, but
they had no way to explain this
using classical physics.
And it turns out that the
Schrodinger equation is an
equation of motion in which
you're describing a particle
by describing it as a wave. So
you're basically having a wave
equation for a particle, and for
our purposes we're talking
about a very particular
particle.
What we're interested
in is the electron.
So basically describing
electrons by their wave-like
properties.
And this is Erwin Schrodinger,
and this is the equation that
he put forth where we have h hat
psi being equal to e psi.
So, let's explain
what these are.
So this symbol here
is actually what
we call a wave function.
That doesn't mean a whole lot
in itself, it will mean more
in about two lectures
from now.
But right now, what I want you
to be thinking of a wave
function as is just some
representation of an electron.
So, it's some way of describing
an electron.
Specifically, we'll talk more
about this, it's talking about
different orbitals, it's the
spatial part of an orbital.
But before we get to that, in
terms of thinking just think,
OK, this is representing my
particle, this is representing
my electron that's what
the wave function is.
This e term here is the energy,
or in our case when we
talk about an electron in a
hydrogen atom, for example,
the binding energy of that
electron to the nucleus.
So, e is binding energy.
And h with the carrot or the hat
here, well, that carrot or
hat tell us it must be an
operator, and this is called
the Hamiltonian operator.
So when you operate on the wave
function, what you end up
with is getting the binding
energy of the electron, and
the wave function back out.
When we need to describe the
wave function term a little
bit more specifically so we can
describe, for example, the
position of the electron, and I
just want to mention that we
do have two choices if we're
trying to describe this, we
could use cartesian coordinates,
or we could use
polar coordinates where we're
either talking about x y z or
r theta and phi.
So, I just want to point out
that when you look at wave
functions, we are going to be
using those spherical polar
coordinates, and the reason is
because a very important
interaction here is the
interaction between the
electron and the nucleus, which
we want to describe the
distance of in terms of r.
So, you can see, it's much
easier to describe that as one
term, r here, instead of
using both y and z.
Another reason I wanted to point
this out in terms of the
polar coordinates that we're
using, is I think they're
actually flipped from
what you're used
to seeing in physics.
Sometimes different disciplines
have different
conventions, which can be very
confusing because the whole
point of what's happening now
is there's so much interplay
between different disciplines,
but still I think this might
be one remaining one where
in our case theta is that
distance from z, that angle
there, where phi is this
distance or angle
from the x-axis.
So just keep it in mind
that it's flipped.
It turns out we won't really
using it, needing to identify
it on the graph so much
in chemistry.
We'll be using the solutions,
so you shouldn't have a
problem, but I wanted to point
it out so it does not look too
strange to you.
In terms of the Schrodinger
equation, we now can write it
in terms of our polar
coordinates here.
So we have the operation on the
wave function in terms of
r, theta, and phi and remember
this e is just our binding
energy for the electron,
and we get back
out this wave function.
So, you might ask, this looks
pretty simple up here, right,
just with that h hat.
It turns out, we can
write it out fully.
It's three different second
derivatives in terms of the
three different parameters.
It's a little bit complicated.
You won't have to solve it in
this class, you can wait till
you get to 18.03 to start
solving these types of
differential equations, and
hopefully, you'll all want the
pleasure of actually solving
the Schrodinger equation at
some point.
So, just keep taking chemistry,
you'll already have
had 18.03 by that point
and you'll have the
opportunity to do that.
What I want to point out also
is that this h hat, the
Hamiltonian operator written out
for the simplest case we
can even imagine, which is a
hydrogen atom where we only
have one electron that we're
dealing with, and of course,
one nucleus.
So you can imagine it's just
going to get more and more
complicated as we get to other
types of atoms, and of course,
molecules from there.
So, we just want to appreciate
that what we'll be using in
this class is, in fact, the
solutions to the Schrodinger
equation, and just so you can
be fully thankful for not
having to necessarily solve
these as we jump into the
solutions and just knowing that
they're out there and
you'll get to solve
it at some point,
hopefully, in your careers.
So, we'll pick up with that,
with some of the solutions and
starting to talk about
energies on Friday.